these are the new Google pixel 3 phones
this is the third generation of
smartphones made by Google under the
pixel brand and it's pretty much the
most optimized version of Android that
you can get on a smartphone we have the
opportunity to get some hands-on time
with the new pixel 3 phones before they
were next here's what you need to do the
first thing you're going to notice about
the new pixel 3 is that it appears to
have the same dual tone construction as
last year's pixel 2 but where last
year's pixel 2 felt like plastic on the
back this is a smooth glass on the
bottom in a shiny glass on top this is
so the phone can support wireless
charging the OLED displays in the pixel
3 are supposed to be improved which is a
good thing because last year's pixel 2
XL phone has some scattered issues with
its OLED display and another you're
going to notice is that the display is
bigger than last year songs Google has
done something similar but apples done
it kept the phone bodies the same size
as previous generations but it basically
made the display bigger using cutouts
and an edge-to-edge display and the
pixel 3 XL has a notch the pixel 3 comes
in three colors this is just black
there's also clearly white and my
personal favorite not pink oh and all I
would say this feels like a really nice
phone I think the construction is
definitely a lot nicer than last year's
pixel - and I like this little color X
in here too some other things that are
new about the pixel 3 phones are running
any Qualcomm Snapdragon 805 processor
which is a bump up from last year's
Snapdragon 835 processor they're
shipping with a brand new mobile
security chip which Google is calling
Titan M this is the same security tip
that Google uses in its data centers
apparently and it's something that's
supposed to protect the data of the lock
screen basically the encrypted disk
anything that's going on in this phone
that's supposed to keep secure it's
going to be passed to this new Titan and
ship it now has an ip68 waterproof
rating and also this is a nice touch it
is shipping with an adapter and USB C
headphones in the box but here's the
thing that's probably going to stand out
the most on these new phones and that's
the camera there are a lot of new camera
features on the new pixel 3 so many in
fact that at the time we did this
hands-on they weren't all totally ready
yet and we couldn't use them all but
we're definitely going to do that once
we get a review phone so stay tuned for
that now some of these new features are
because of hardware upgrades for example
the rear lens and the camera has been
improved and the front camera now has 2
wide-angle lens which means you can take
really wide-angle selfies which is
pretty fun and Google says that it's
visual core which is it's imaging
coprocessor on the phone has been
updated and that more camera related
tasks have been given to the core but a
lot of the camera updates in this phone
are using sophisticated software because
that's what Google is really good at I
mean for example this camera lens on the
back still a single lens camera and yet
goal is still able to do something like
depth adjustment on a portrait photo
after the fact which is something it's
competitors also do but it's doing it
with software there's a feature called
top shot which captures a motion photo
and then using AI picks the best still
image so that if someone was blinking or
a hair was in their face or they were
just making a goofy face top shot would
pick a pretty decent picture for you
there's also a feature called photo
booth which was borrowed from the Google
clicks camera where you open photo booth
and then once you raise your phone and
it recognizes that you're smiling it
will start taking a series of images of
you from the front-facing cameras so
basically you don't even have to think
about photo taking there's a night mode
that has a longer exposure and pulls in
as much visual information as possible
to create a composite of your photos
taken in the dark but even if they're
taking in a really dim or dark setting
they look pretty decent there's
something called super resume that's
using machine learning to counter the
shaking of your hand when you use
optical zoom to zoom in
something really tight and then to
create a photo that looks more
high-resolution and people with kids or
cats are gonna love this
there's a motion autofocus feature as
well that keeps the camera focused on a
moving object as you're trying to take a
picture of it basically Google is using
a lot of AI and machine learning to make
your photos look as good as possible
even when you are moving or your subject
is moving or you're taking a photo in
the dark or even you don't feel like
manually taking the photo at all it's a
very Google approach to improving a
phone's camera functions another really
interesting feature that's launching
with Pixar 3 is that Google will screen
your calls for you it's called call
screen Wow the person you're calling if
you're gonna screening service and look
at a copy of this conversation when an
unknown number is calling your pixel 3
an automated voice is initially going to
answer the call for you and then it will
show you a bunch of options the bottom
of the screen here to basically take you
through a conversation with the person
who is calling and make them explain why
they're calling this is a great idea if
it's a spam call because if someone says
you wanna cruise or you're late on your
mortgage or something like that you can
just reject the call you'll see it in a
transcription but if it's someone
legitimate like your dentist but you
just don't have their number saved
you'll know that you should swipe to
answer it so how much are these new
pixel 3 phones going to cost you the
pixel 3 starts at $7.99 for a
configuration with 64 gigabytes of
storage and the control three XL starts
at 899 which puts it right in line with
last year's phones and also less than
the new iPhones you start shipping
October 18 another gadget that Google is
launching is this pixel stand which
costs $79 it's supposed to fast charge
of the phones wirelessly and also turns
the phone's display into something of a
smart display so far it seems like these
new pixel phones are a little more
flashy than they usually are in terms of
their build but per usual what's most
interesting about these phones is what's
going on on the inside Google doesn't
have the same industrial design pedigree
that Apple or Sam
so it tries to make up for it by making
the smartest phone in the room let's see
if it works
[Music]